is that
is that a super rare valuable trait in
somebody to be able to
murder without emotion
oh yeah there's and the truth that it is
because
most of the guys that i know aren't that
way
like you know even sammy sammy you know
uh he told me he says i never you know
pete they got me like i love kill i
don't i hate it i hate
he says and when i get when i have to do
it he says i'm so mad at the person for
breaking the rule and forcing me to have
to do this
you know it's business it's it's it's
hard to realize that but
uh and they say the human body can get
used to anything you could endure
anything and
eventually it just becomes a way of life
you know
uh but yeah but greg greg could kill you
uh like there was a a lawyer that once
described him as
good-looking articulate uh
he said something like he could sit down
with judges and lawyers
have dinner with you and for dessert
he'll kill you
that's how he described greg so i'm i'm
curious
about like what
what kind of like human traits did you
notice in a guy like this
gregory who that makes him able to just
murder somebody
well you know it's the same thing it's
it's it becomes second nature he
he he was a he was born in the life
i mean at 15 16 years old he was already
in the street
stealing beating people up doing all the
things that
uh so he's conditioned very very young
an up-and-coming
guy and somebody that's already in the
life sees this trait in him sees that
he's
he's uh he's tough uh he's got balls
he's got you know got what it takes okay
and then they groom you okay i was
groomed i was taught i
educated the way to life uh
i don't think that's happening anymore
today because i could see the different
people that are in the life
now uh it's not the same it's definitely
not the same
they they miss that grooming and
teaching and and having a
person become a consummate wise guy that
when you walk into a place
they know who you are you don't have to
tell them this this guy's
uh somebody to respect and greg always
had that
he got straightened out i think he was
18. he got his button
what does that mean uh when you get made
into the family okay officially inducted
okay become an official member of the
family
uh to have it at that age you had to
have somebody that saw
a lot about you uh and he loved money
he loved money so there's nothing he
wouldn't do to earn money
i mean every racket there was he was in
uh you know from joker poker machines to
the number business [ __ ] and
he was a [ __ ] to shylocks what's a
[ __ ] you lend money
uh at exorbitant rates so you give a guy
a thousand dollars
and you could charge anywhere from he
would charge me ten dollars but i would
charge
30 40 or 50 per week that's the interest
they have to pay that every week
until they hand you back to thousands
okay so he had
uh he was making i mean just what i knew
about
from the close guys
about 25 000 a week in interest every
week
without fail nobody missed payments all
the people that
were getting these loans from him knew
that the collateral was their life yes
well their their well-being right you
know he would probably they're going to
kill them with their legs
broken right we went to work on guys all
the time that didn't pay
and uh even that become you know second
nature
it you know they start you out
where you're doing uh where somebody are
beating up
did something very bad like robbed an
old woman in the neighborhood
okay or found out they were selling
drugs by the school
we go give them a beating you feel proud
in a way you think you did the right
thing you got this drug dealer away from
the school
or you got even with the uh this person
that rob some
a friend's grandmother you know then
you participate just because a guy owes
money
but you're already seasoned they take
baby steps they never ask you to kill
your friend
that's like a myth like your best friend
no they're not going to have movies
right the ones they're going to ask you
to kill
is somebody again early on somebody that
did something really bad
later on it becomes looser
this guy you know had a fight with uh
junior person goes nephew and junior
personal's nephew lost the fight
we have to go kill the guy i mean it's a
fight
yeah i got fights growing up if i if i i
would have been killed five times
for winning a fight you know i lost
fights too don't get me wrong but
uh it's just uh i actually got called to
a meeting
uh that i had a i was in the after hours
and we weren't supposed to be in after
hours
what's the after hours okay the the
nightclubs close at four o'clock uh-huh
and there's clubs that open it for oh
[ __ ] yeah and they're illegal
but you know they were all around uh
so i was in one of these places and i
get a beef with uh
i find out later on it's paul
castellano's nephew i didn't know
and he picked a bad time because
i was really at the peak of my martial
arts i was good
and i won the fight okay i didn't abuse
him i didn't keep hitting when he was
down once he went down and
i walked away it was over the next night
i get a call
i have to go to the diner
and it's like late at night almost
morning
it's one of those 24-hour diners you
know and
i'm thinking to myself oh
why do i gotta go see greg two o'clock
in the morning you know it's
a little oh it's greg you had to go see
him well he's doing that call for me
right
so i get there i see sammy the bull
hanging out outside
he says hello to me i walk in who's
sitting
scappy our captain greg
and paul castellano
you're [ __ ] yourself i i no i don't
know what happened yet
greg now comes over to me and walks me
outside or to the front door
and he says what happened last night i
said what are you talking about i said i
we went out i said you got a beef i said
oh yeah i got a fight i said
you know this you know what happened
once in a while
he says well that was paulie's nephew so
i didn't know
and he's telling me he wants
satisfaction he wants to kill me
so scappy but i learned the lesson here
too so scappy
is talking on our behalf he's captain he
was
he was a boss for a while very well
respected and
uh so i remember
now he's paul's talking to me he says if
it wasn't for scappy
okay you'd be dead already
now greg got married so he says if the
hair is harmed on his head
i said you'll find more bodies in the
street now scappy had
to greg you know he shouldn't have said
that but
he's feared paul would have [ __ ] his
pants if they had to go to war together
you know paul was no greg right he was a
boss and he was a businessman
so anyway long story short i had to like
i owed scappy my life now right because
he saved me
so now i owed him what kind of a guy was
scappy
a scabby old-school old-time mob guy
that died in prison
uh he got a 133 years
and he's the guy that they quoted the
newspaper when he got the 133 years he
looked at junior personnel he says well
we only got to do two-thirds
and it was in the newspaper and when he
got the time he was about
65 so obviously he was never coming home
junior never came home
uh so anyway the funny part of this is
after it's over with
i walk outside i talked to sammy real
quick and he said
while i'm walking away he says she
should have killed that [ __ ]
[ __ ] he didn't like the kid so that was
funny
yeah so sammy did sami kind of have your
back too with sami
same gang no he was he was there to be
with uh
he was the other guy he was yeah yeah
with paul castle
[ __ ] the gambino family but we were
friends so he says we we had a rapport
you know
and uh he knew me so if this guy would
have had his way
sammy would have been the guy to kill
you oh yeah that's a good question i
don't
that's a good question uh
could be could be that's a great
question i don't know that
yeah i i don't think greg would have
allowed me to get in the car there and
then the other thing is this
typically they won't let somebody else
do it
if it came down to and i'll tell you a
story where i had to be killed
my own family would do it they wouldn't
allow the gambinos to do it
i